hey you guys I'm Ryan right
I'm Jerry we're gonna check out this
trailer for something called jaws 19
very excited before you that I wanted to
mention this is a sponsored video slash
shout out for Full Sail University we've
talked about them before they're a
fantastic University here's how I'll say
this to you I mean if you've ever
thought about becoming a filmmaker you
want to learn the ins and outs of the
technical side you know how to shoot how
to light how to edit you know maybe
write then go to Full Sail check out
their various film degree programs as
well as their programs for music video
games you know they got a lot of
different stuff yeah the online digital
cinematography program you'll learn what
it takes to write shoot edit your own
films and they'll provide you with a
professional video camera and a computer
too if you need one all sorts of
industry software and stuff like yeah a
MacBook Pro if I'm not mistaken they
also offer a film production master's
degree program creative writing degree
programs that are at a bachelor's and
master's level so from from the basic to
the premium extreme yeah and like Jerry
said earlier there's music gaming other
entertainment industry offers there's a
link in the description box so if you
actually want to you know get a little
bit more knowledgeable if you're serious
about pursuing your dreams in the film
industry
check out Full Sail University link in
description box seems like a good place
for friend you in there yeah at least
one probably more but it's in the
meantime let's see what you know a
little bit about jaws 19 right yeah
actually a friend of mine put this
together at least early it grew from
there I remember many months ago at the
old coffee shop he would come in and
tell me about this this jaws anthology
he was putting together with some some
people he knew and then pretty soon it
hadn't expanded out here it was like Tim
League got on board or somebody but but
now you know now it's at Universal let's
see what jaws 19 is all about
or say too much for we gonna do jaws
make you afraid to go in the water jaws
to make you afraid to go back in the
water
jaws 3d was a new dimension in terror in
Jaws for the revenge it was personal
then it was just business then pure
pleasure cyber jaws make you afraid to
log on and lower jaws make you afraid of
robotic sharks then chief Brody's
grandson assembled a super team of shark
hunters jaws 10 it was man vs. shark
versus the terrors of the deep outer
space then a prequel and a sequel to the
prequel and then a new era in terror
began Jaws started a family battle the
Russian shark named Ivan shark offski
took a bite out of the Big Apple and
burned about love from a mysterious
stranger jaws 18 origins the
mind-blowing reboot now the oceans are
disappearing and to save their home the
sharks must attend jaws 19 this time
it's really really personal
[Music]
is that real yeah like it's a real movie
they're gonna make yeah it's an
anthology so they're gonna make like a
bunch of different jaws movies that are
just gonna make jaws 19 no no it's a
bunch of J I think it's its jaws 5
through 19 interesting it's like all
different you know it's an anthology of
all jaws related shark truly just a
bunch of spoofs of like what a bunch of
crazy ridiculous sequels with me yeah
that's funny yeah I don't know where
where it is now but yeah and my buddy
would come in and sort of just talk
about sort of the process as it was
ongoing and it really grew from the
beginning so that's what yeah great idea
as of my understanding is it's a bunch
of different filmmakers doing some kind
of shark related jaws related stories
that's cool because I've seen plenty of
movies that are like making fun of like
what a sequel would be and stuff you
know you get the montage of ending of 22
Jump Street yeah Tropic Thunder they do
it with Ben Stiller's character ain't no
there's other parodies we've seen of
like sequels they're actually putting an
anthology film together of all these
Jaws films that's that's different it's
better than just some montage oh yeah
that's clever man I really want to see
jaws in space well yeah then it was for
a lot of very fun variety I would
imagine it seems like it's in good humor
I want to see the different kinds of
Jocelyn's I think it would be great if
they got like different directors for
each one of the Jaws ones if they get
there oh that's so they're actually
gonna be getting like different
filmmakers per jaws movie yeah that was
the point as like my buddy was working
on his one and then there were people
coming on board with ideas and stuff
like that and each one is a different
team this you can be exciting and the
universals putting it together now yeah
that's cool it is gone very far since
its I'm glad to see Universal has a
pretty big sense of humor about the
whole thing
cuz you would expect that from a huge
movie studio to do something like that
you know take a classic and like make
and do us this sequel parodies it's
because jaws became so campy already
yeah it seems like they're embracing you
know this is kind of a modern thing in a
lot of ways and it seems like instead of
you know railing against it they're
recognizing the opportunities you know
whatever clever marketing yeah you know
to keep things cheeky and and Creature
Features are big
now you got a lot of different people so
I imagine you know there were there was
money coming in from well yeah well you
know they sound malarious it sounds
really funny I hope they get Richard
Dreyfuss back yes I hope I hope they do
and I hope Spielberg directs one of them
I'm sure he halted bridge of spies for
this yeah anyway guys thanks for tuning
in to the channel if you're new to it
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and get become a reject yeah whatever
you can get rejected get rejected so you
won't be a lot of subscribe ostracized
from the greater parts of society but
you'll be here with that and you can
check out our Jer bears channel playlist
on this reason this is Jerry check it
out and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope